how long and that's certainly one of the
things they'll be doing sheriff did you
have a sense that he
understood the gravity of what he did
um when i was i spoke with investigators
they interviewed him this morning and i
they got that impression that yes he
understood
the gravity of it and he was pretty much
fed up and then
at the end of his rope and uh and
yesterday was a really bad day for him
and this is what he did
uh i'm not going to go to i don't know
if he was remorseful or not he mentioned
florida 21 years of age
it's my understanding he does not live
with his parents i don't know who he was
living with at the time of this
incident i'm not aware of that either
that's some of the things
we put out an image of a possible
suspect very early on
in this incident and we were notified
by his family who were fully cooperative
and we're greatly appreciative
of their assistance in this matter
surveillance cameras there were several
businesses there and we were able to get
images from those
and then also i did his car also from
the
the car and then of course obviously we
were able to get in touch with parents
who identified it from social media that
was their child
you mentioned florida were there any did
he mention any particular
businesses that he was going after um
just
my understanding of some type of porn
industry in that state that he was
wanting to go do some
similar act in that location no
additional details at this time
he did he did make that claim despite
there not
being racial motivation there has been a
very real set of
anti-aging hate attacks across the
country we heard from new york city
police that they're actually
sending resources out of an abundance of
caution to their asian communities
across the city
now for any of the law enforcement
partners here is there anything
similar as far as strategy and extra
support for either
the asian american communities in metro
atlanta or similar businesses like
massage parlors
so obviously whatever the motivation um
was for this guy we know
that many of the victims the majority of
the victims were asian
we also know that this is an issue
that's happening across the country
it is unacceptable it is hateful
and it has to stop
that being said we are coordinating
in real time to make sure that our
communities have the resources that they
need
we have not seen a significant uptick
in formal complaints within the city of
atlanta but obviously this is a large
metropolitan region and we know that we
are
we're hearing the stories we're seeing
them on television we're
seeing them on social media so we
certainly are aware
and we stand ready to provide any
additional resources
but again because of the quick
coordination when i
i was on my way home from city hall last
night when i received
the alert that there was a business
shooting on piedmont road
i immediately called chief brian who had
already been in touch with
cherokee county and they were already
making the connection
so we had a very rapid response
but certainly we will continue to be
proactive and provide
resources to the extent that we can to
make sure that our communities are
protected and again
encouraging anyone we know many
many of our communities are sometimes
hesitant to bring in law enforcement
if there are things and concerns that
are happening
in your communities around your
businesses etc there's nothing too big
or too small that we
uh we want to be aware of it all to make
sure that we can provide resources and
and respond accordingly
i can tell you that a nine millimeter
firearm was located in his vehicle
when he was taken into custody um you
know whether it was legally obtained
one of the things that our investigators
will be looking into and just to be
clear
our victims i know that obviously
atlanta their all their victims were
asian
two of our victims were white in case
anyone was unaware of that we had two
asians and two whites that were killed
at our location
that's one of the things that this time
we're not going to go into details about
while they were there
well obviously we'll have to do
forensics on the on the uh firearm but
we're confident that it is
the only weapon yes yes
is
opinion that he was acting alone there's
no indication that anyone was working
with him so
we're confident that's not gonna be a
problem
he made a comment to that effect that he
was headed to florida
and that he was going to do similar acts
in that state
had been tempting him it sounds to me
like the these this these locations he
sees them as an outlet for him that some
things that he shouldn't be doing
and that an issue with porn and that
he was attempting to take out that
temptation and he had visited both of
those locations before
apartments he had visited both of those
locations i'm unaware if he'd been to
those specific locations
one more anybody
what was the conversation with this
family is there anything you can share
about you know i don't want to go into
details other than to say that
we are i'm really appreciative of the
family without them this would not have
happened as well
as quickly as it happened they were very
supportive
and certainly this was difficult for
them did he resist it all during the
arrival no no he did not resist
that's right thank you thank you
and by the way i'll bring out our press
release and put it out here for y'all
come on someone left
i will have i'm going to go over the
list of who spoke in the order that they
spoke if you're ready
and i'll have the spelling will be on
the table but it's not necessarily in
the order that they spoke in
of course the first person to speak was
mayor keisha lance bottoms
the second was chief rodney bryant of
the atlanta police department
the third person was sheriff frank
reynolds of the cherokee county
sheriff's office
fourth person was lieutenant mark riley
of the georgia state patrol
and fifth was captain jay baker of
cherokee county sheriff's office
mark riley and i'll have the list over
on the table
it just it's just not in the same order
but the names are on the list
you